if Republicans win in parts of the
country where Democrats once ruled it's
going to largely be due to the dramatic
shift to the right by Latinos who are
fed up with the cost of living they're
fed up like Leora said with crime and a
radicalized school curricula we haven't
talked about that yet well the New York
time zone reporting shows that many who
are supporting the GOP on the most
important issues facing the country are
those exact issues a focus group
comprised of Hispanics across Texas
Florida and Arizona showed that they
thought Republicans were stronger on a
variety of issues such as crime safety
gun control National Security
immigration and the economy now larger
polls have also showed a significant
shift rightward according to the
executive director of the National
Association of Latino elected and
appointed officials five weeks into our
tracking poll it's becoming clear that
Republicans have gained significant
ground with latino voters since the last
midterm cycle
so why is this happening
the fact of the matter is that we you
know we don't feel safe anymore at times
like these it's really economic concerns
that that that take priority
um and and that's what you're seeing is
the Hispanic Community is dealing with
you know uh High interest rates uh
energy costs record high inflation and
historically it's been the Republican
party that focuses on those economic
issues identify more with the Republican
party what things
well we're for God country family and
hard work
joining me now is Florida congresswoman
Maria Salazar congresswoman great to see
you tonight
um Latino voters they don't need
pandering from Democrats because it
seems like from everything I've read and
all the surveys done they care about the
same things that everyone else does
of course thank you for having me we're
not martians we're Americans and this
year is going to be 2020 is going to be
the year of the Hispanic Republicans
thank God for that we're waking up and
why is that because we have the same
values that are entrenched in the
Republican Party
God-fearing law-abiding tax paying low
taxes small government and family
oriented that's what we are and thank
God that we are waking up to the fact
that for 30 years the Democratic party
has been playing political football with
us and you know why I can say it because
before getting to Congress I was on
television I'm one of the founders of
Spanish television Univision and
Telemundo and those are my viewers and I
know that my community wants
doesn't does not want to open borders we
want to have an orderly border we want
to have low inflations we want to be
able to raise our kids live in dignity
which is the bill that I presented the
Immigration Reform Bill and we want to
live in the promised land and contribute
with the economy so it's time for us to
wake up and thank God we're doing it and
the GOP is welcoming us and I am the
best example in 2020 I was the biggest
upset in the country because my people
are not socialists no I love that I we
covered it at the time it was awesome
because there's a lot of bad news for
people in 2022 but your opponent
congresswoman went on Al Sharpton show
over the weekend and surprised to attack
you watch
my mega Republican opponent is
definitely out of step with our district
in Miami politicians love to talk about
freedom in Cuba Nicaragua Venezuela we
understand that freedom in those
countries means that we have to defend
democracy right here in America and
that's not what my opponent has done
congresswoman they care about freedom
and the preservation of American
Standards and dignity after what they've
put us through over the past few years
listen the problem with my opponents is
that and not only her but the whole
Democratic party is that they have to
defend the undefendable they have to
defend something called Democratic
socialism and that's why I was able to
win in 2020 against one of the bastions
of the democratic party the
longest-serving member of the Clinton
Administration Mrs Donna Shalala she was
the president of the Clinton foundation
and I was able to unseat her it was the
only District in the country where Biden
won the district and the Democratic
incumbent was unceded why because we
Hispanics were not socialists
understanding Congressman we have to run
but I am so excited about this trend I'm
so excited across the country what we're
seeing it's a common sense uh Latino
movement and it's it's a beautiful thing
to say thank you so much